but what do you think of the Elon and
Mark fight
I mean Mark is like send location you
know he's I mean like yeah
understandably so he's not [__]
jacked wait did I go in on the
conspiracy theory about him and this MMA
fighter no
there's this conspiracy people have and
this could be you know I maybe didn't
read into it enough
that
um this MMA fighter Mackenzie Dern any
relation to Laura Dern no no no bummer
sorry oh Dern bummer oh Dern darn it
so the timeline supposedly is this
little T spill like I love this little
teaspoon I love for everybody for the
Gang
so I guess the timeline is that Mark
Zuckerberg
uh
uh states that Mackenzie Dern is his
favorite fighter
then yeah she's a lady
and then
like during covid
when they were doing fights in the Apex
Center okay
supposedly look this up did he buy
the [__] like I someone said he
bought out the arena it's a small room
but that so he could go watch her fight
okay and it's just him in the audience
yes and she's fighting nobody no she's
fighting yeah yeah she's in the middle
of the Ring yeah no it was like a
sanction yeah you look so good out there
now she's getting divorced
and now Mark is training jiu jitsu
and she
is a you know
Jiu Jitsu practitioner okay at a high
level okay
is he training with her I I want to say
something to that too I don't want to
[__] make this up promotion revealed
that the event would be close to fans
and media
speculation quickly began to run rampant
before media day
LED one half of the main event Mackenzie
Dern to share the best of her knowledge
that Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg had
rented out the UFC Apex facility oh but
what is the T spill that they're like
having in there people are just yeah
theorizing that Mark Marky Mark is
zoning in on
Miss Dern wow you saw Zuck in his first
Jiu Jitsu tournament uh yeah that was a
while ago right yeah yeah and he won
yeah
he looked weird out there did he yeah
pull it up you look weird his Jujitsu
style or what just yeah his body he's
just like he's learning how to use it
okay yeah you know it's like he's very
upright
all right
and uh he clearly knows what he's doing
though oh yeah no no no he's not
incompetent by any means but
and I guess I should also say when I say
he looked weird out there it's also
objectively weird to see the Facebook
CEO
yeah I feel like
I would be kind of nervous if I was the
other guy let's see look at this
takedown
but you know
just fell into a guillotine
like you can't really go too hard on him
no in Jiu Jitsu you yeah yes you can no
problem saying you're the other guy and
at no point in this fight does it cross
your mind that oh my God this guy's a
[__] billionaire he could destroy me
no because Jiu Jitsu is one of the
sports like Combat Sports that you can
almost train at a hundred percent that's
the problem is that people go 100
regardless of who you are you might be
like a first timer in there and so you
lock in with some brown belt and he's
like what's up brother welcome to the
gym and then you're [__] you're like
my neck hurts yeah because that's what I
mean but no so I'm I hear you but I'm
saying I don't think they hold back I
think when they see Mark Zuckerberg get
on the mat they're like he's like [__]
this guy I'm a [__] choke out not
even eat the rich just it doesn't matter
who this guy is yes I think that's the
mindset we are rolling brother yeah yeah
yeah
but then maybe after the fact Mark's
like ow and the dude's like oh [__]
I'm [__] maybe that I think there's
probably yeah I'm not discounting what
you're saying there's definitely
probably been moments like that okay
okay so here is like a little moment
like where he's like trying to force his
way in right here
that he looks weird oh yeah he just he
just looks a little odd like this yeah
just getting comfortable yeah yeah
you know he could [__] both of us up
though on the mats yeah
that's the thing about America you know
a gun just sorry
something about a gun you know that just
makes it makes a fight a lot easier yeah
it is weird to see him do like normal
people [__] mm-hmm
because we've only ever seen him uh Jiu
Jitsu yeah doing that
it's uh uh one of my favorite pastimes
right now yeah
but here's the thing
he's also looking yoked yeah he's
[__] jacked did you see the Murph
thing
no you didn't see the Murph challenge
like on Father's Day no was it Father's
Day
search Mark Zuckerberg Murph challenge
do you know what that is no it's like a
hundred push-ups 100 pull-ups and you
run five miles or something like that I
tried to do the Murph challenge with the
girls every Memorial Day is a tradition
to honor those who defended us one of
Lieutenant Murphy's favorite workouts
was running a mile then doing 100
pull-ups 200 push-ups 300 squats and
then running another mile all while
wearing a 20 pound weighted pack this
year I got done within 39.58 then 40
minutes that's what I'm saying that's
[__] insane it's fast
so fast dude 300 200 push-ups you got to
be scared when a billionaire 20 pound
weight of vest on you got to be scared
you got to be jacked when a billionaire
who could buy a spaceship and avoid all
this is training hard as [__] yeah why
why what why do you know exactly what
the [__] do you know yeah
it's scary right it just says some [__]
like that at the end
just getting prepared dot dot yeah for
what hold on bro hold on dude hold up
what if you just turn he's just a Chad
now and he's just [__] with people
yeah he's like as he's posting this he's
like yo watch this just getting prepared
they're gonna go nuts yo McKenzie watch
that [__]
hahaha
damn I don't want to start any rumors
man
I'm sure I'm sure Mark doesn't care nah
yeah
I know me Mark text man I Gotta Be You
know I gotta be gotta be careful what I
say yeah that's true yeah you guys are
Pals yeah well he he can read all our
texts yeah exactly
he can read whatever he wants but
I would love it if
he just took this crazy Arc
and he actually knocked Elon Musk the
[__] out he would dude if he did that
people are like I I'm on Facebook man
I'll stick with oculus yeah I'm down I'm
gonna give that a try yo oh my God what
if after like all the conservative and
right-wing user base that he's
identified on Facebook he's just
collected a bunch of data and his team
goes
Mark we believe the best thing right now
is if you were to
become the next David Goggins yeah yeah
they go what like we've done the
research if you could punch out Elon
Musk We believe We Could recruit 30 of
Twitter users he's like I will do it Dad
yeah easy yeah bet
anything for the growth yeah
and he would walk in there and just oh
one elbow yeah completely lay him out
Elon is an oddly built guy
so
I'm imagining him trying to learn how to
fight
like the rate at which Mark has
progressed in Jiu Jitsu and the time
that he's been doing it is pretty good
yeah he's like he's learned how to use
his body a little bit but
could Elon achieve that same success I I
doubt it like why are you I hate that
we're even talking about this like
obviously it's not gonna happen it
shouldn't happen and if it does happen
then the internet should be [__]
destroyed
do you know what I'm saying
I want to challenge you on these guys
are running the [__] the biggest
companies in the world they should not
be doing this [__] they don't do [__]
this one that's he shouldn't be fighting
we should we should never get to see
that I would love it